so good afternoon everybody I'm penny
Lorenz a member of the inaugural
committee I'm delighted to welcome you
today to the Provost to president panel
the final symposium of this inaugural
weekend I know you realize we have an
extraordinarily distinguished panel and
I hope you realize that you are a very
distinguished audience leaders with Yale
connections around the world I'm
reminded that on welcoming a group of
Nobel Prize winners to the White House
President Kennedy famously said I think
this is the most extraordinary
collection of human knowledge that has
ever been gathered at the White House
with the possible exception of when
Thomas Jefferson dined alone I I would
propose that this today is the most
astonishing collection of institutional
leadership that has ever been gathered
at Yale with the possible exception of
when Ezra Stiles dined alone when I
first imagined this panel I think some
of the committee members doubted that
the four exceptionally busy people we
hope to participate could be got here on
one day its testimony to the tremendous
support for Yale's 23rd president and
for Yale itself that all of them agreed
to come despite their crowded schedules
and I know Peter and all of us are
extremely grateful I wish to take just a
second to point out that there are other
Provost's here today who became
presidents or vice chancellors a real
pride of Provost's as it were there's
Andy Hamilton who was on the last panel
who was the Provost at Yale from 2004 to
2008 and is now Vice Chancellor of
Oxford there's Gerhard Kasper who was
the Provost at the University of Chicago
and then became the president of
Stanford this Kathryn Hill who was the
Provost of Williams and became the
president of Vassar there's George Juan
who's the president of NUS and became
the president of NUS that's a real pride
of Provost and let's of course not
forget Peter salivate
was Provost at Yale from 2008 to 2013 as
now becoming Yale's president this panel
is for him at his the laboratory moment
because it especially honors his
trajectory with that said I am now ready
to introduce to you our panelists an
order you all know them please helmet
warmly help help me warmly welcome
Hannah Holborn GRA Provost at Yale from
74 to 77 president of Yale from 77 to 78
and president emeritus at the University
of Chicago Sue's yes
Susan Hockfield Dean of the Graduate
School from 1998 to 2002 Provost at Yale
2003-2004 and president emeritus of MIT
Allisyn Richard Provost at Yale 1994 to
2002 and Vice Chancellor emeritus of the
University of Cambridge
Judith rode in Dean of the graduate
school 1991-92 Provost at Yale 92 to 94
president emeritus 'ti of Pennsylvania
and president of the Rockefeller
Foundation
and of course the moderator of the panel
Margaret Marshall former Chief Justice
of the Massachusetts Supreme Judicial
Court and senior fellow of the Yale
Corporation thank you
so this afternoon we're going to have a
conversation hence the change of the
shape of the table it takes a long time
to figure that out it really will be a
conversation but I have to say provost
at Yale president of Chicago 12 octa
president of MIT Provost at Yale advice
Chancellor of Cambridge University
Provost at Yale president to the
University of Pennsylvania
is that worth celebrating
so Hannah gray you grew up in New Haven
you were the daughter of probably one of
our most distinguished historians and I
don't think this is a violation of the
Age Discrimination Act you are so old
that you met President angel the moment
you met President angel and I'm told you
were wearing your best party dress and
patent leather shoes and I want to know
whether that's when you decided to
become a president of the universe well
somebody is tackling I'm afraid but I
was recalling I'm returning to New Haven
that my family came here 79 years ago
and perhaps the second Sunday that we
were in our house and spring Glenn I was
put into my Sunday best of my patent
leather shoes and told to behave myself
or else and a very large car drew up in
front of the house and president and
mrs. angel were coming to call they came
to call on every new member of the
faculty Peter
at that time there were very few members
it was the depression and people were
actually being laid off instead and then
two weeks later another car drove up in
front of the house my patent leather
shoes were back on and Provost Seymour
and his wife turned up and so at a very
early age I learned what it sort of
washed over me what a president and a
Provost of Yale supposedly did and I
grew up in New Haven went to the foot
school actually went with children of
administrators at Yale who seemed like
almost normal people and at the same
time very remote they were generally
talked about quite respectfully until
they did something stupid which was not
infrequently according to the faculty
colleagues who congregated from time to
time to discuss these matters so by and
large it seemed like a good relationship
and a respectful one what I would love
to graduate school the last thing on my
mind was that I would ever do
administration the only thing on my mind
was whether I would be able to have an
academic career at all there was not a
time when women were necessarily welcome
in that world and when I got engaged and
married I was told that that would be
the end of any ambitions of that sort
that I want to entertain and I also
gained a father-in-law
who was a professor at a very different
major but very different University he
used to refer to his president as that
little sparrow
and whenever the little sparrow chirped
there would be derisive and ruthless
criticisms of the little sparrow and of
the decisions always the wrong decisions
that he had arrived at and I received
from my father-in-law the view that
administrators were somehow somewhat
disreputable that they were failed
academics that they had sold out that
they were probably no better than
weak-kneed politicians and that by and
large I could not imagine that it was a
group to which I would ever want to
belong all I wanted to do was to be an
academic so I became an academic I was
fortunate I went to graduate school with
eight other women in my cohort two of us
got PhDs and one of us had a career it
was that it was that period and I then
went with a husband to the University of
Chicago where he was appointed and to my
astonishment because in those days
universities were not appointing spouses
let alone in the same department a year
later I was offered an appointment I'm
so grateful to the University that I
would do anything they ever asked me to
do teach courses on subjects I knew very
little about join committees that needed
people to join them and take on very
very minor administrative roles of
cheering this chairing that curricular
programs and so on and so forth but over
time I discovered that I rather enjoy
organizing these things and that I
rather enjoyed the process of bringing
people together around rather
complicated issues even complicated well
you know there's nothing more
complicated than a curricular discussion
and sort of trying to tease out ways in
which one could talk to one another and
in which one could come if not to total
agreement certainly to a next move and
some consensus on these issues and that
seemed to me a kind of central process
that was interesting to do and that
not entirely unrelated to teaching and
so I suppose that was how I first came
to the view that maybe there was a life
there although it wasn't one that I
aspired to scholar in psychology you
were an outstanding teacher and you were
a great mentor to Peter salivate
what on earth persuaded you to give up
that life to take on the one that you
did you're blaming Peter and I think
that's right those moments in the lab
you know I think I too never really
thought that that would be the
trajectory I was very fortunate here we
were working in a new field behavioral
medicine and health psychology it was
developing very quickly and Yale gave me
the opportunity to have a triple joint
appointment in psychology medicine and
psychiatry and that was quite unique at
the time and we ran a big lab we had
amazing students like Peter and when I
was first asked to take on an
administrative position my son was three
years old and that was department chair
and I said no I can't deal with the
babies in the department I have a baby
at home a couple of years later when
Alex was already in school I did become
department chair and it was really
fantastic enabling your colleagues to do
something and and to help others really
do it well so it wasn't administration I
hope it was leadership sometimes it was
management and herding cats but often it
was leadership and I think from from
there and you read my dates the
trajectory was pretty quick I kept my
lab going all the time and someone once
described an academic leader an academic
administrator
Yale as someone who steps out from the
faculty for a moment like a Roman chorus
Jake's yes she was proud and takes that
moment and then steps back to the chorus
and so for that reason I kept my lab
going I taught all of those years but
Penn for me was a different trajectory
it was going home to Philadelphia I was
the first penile um to become president
unlike the Yale tradition and obviously
the first woman president in the Ivy
League so it was irresistible great and
president Hockfield you have always
loved science science is your passion
what drew you to put your tippy toe into
the waters of administration yeah well
like my colleagues academic leadership
was never a career ambition and having
grown up in the 60s the suspicion of
authority was rampant as a scientist you
know your job is to do something that's
never been done before and throw off all
the shackles of tradition in the past
and so I guess I would kind of describe
myself as a bit of an anarchist in the
delighted scientist with no ambition to
take on any kind of role in leadership
so what changed your mind
well I'm Rick and Alison
actually for me I had a bit of um I
would say a stumble into science and for
me you know probably the most
transformational experience of my life
was going to graduate school it was
absolutely intoxicating to be surrounded
by people who love the same thing I
loved and to be just pushing forward I
mean fighting out for that frontier of
knowledge it's exhilarating beyond any
description and so my graduate school
experience had been so important in my
personal development obviously the
development of my career when Rick and
Alison approached me about taking on the
deanship of the Graduate School my first
response was yeah who me you know please
know but then as I thought about it I
realized that it would be possible for
me to help create conditions at Yale
University where more graduate students
might be able to have that powerful
transformational experience in their
lives
and so I said you know okay maybe for
three years I might do this I'm going to
keep my lab because I'm going back to Oz
Brown model and it was only in becoming
part of the Levantine so Rick and Alison
dick Radha had and I became the quartet
and I discovered the incredible I
wouldn't say power individual part but
the incredible ability to convene people
to bring them together to come up with
directions forward that were better for
you know the individuals in the
university better for the university
over overall and it just became a really
compelling new occupation and so even
though this wasn't the career I intended
I just felt it was it's been an enormous
privilege to have had two careers in a
lifetime both of which have been very
exciting but I have to say many days
when I got to the lab I would just kind
of look around and smile and say boy I
wonder what I'm going to do when I grow
up
academic leadership is not for the faint
of heart
and within you know perhaps not ours but
certainly weeks of having become Dean of
the Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
here I just left myself well this is
what you're doing when you grow up honey
so Vice Chancellor Richard Allison did
you know what you were pulling Susan
into when you approached her and told
her that to give up her lab and give up
science and give up that sense of
exhilaration oh yes so the story of my
life and this all sort of resonates
you've all been saying in 1989 Benno
Schmidt asked me if I would consider
throwing my hat into the ring to become
director at the Peabody Museum and I
said no my children are too young I
couldn't take that on at this moment and
he said oh well would you serve on the
search committee and I said absolutely I
think the Peabody is really important
and I'd really wanted to flourish so for
two years I pitched this job to various
wonderful candidates telling them what a
great job it was and none of them took
it so in the two years later I didn't
hear fellow crack many jokes but in 1991
Boehner came back to me and he said well
this search has gone on so long your
children must have grown out
and actually there was some truth in it
so so I became director at the Peabody
Museum and became known in our family as
her the queen of the dinosaurs and I
love that I really really love doing bad
and then in nineteen nineteen ninety
four Ric approached me to become Provost
and I said I can't do that I'm not an
economist and he said don't worry I've
got that covered but it was Judy I went
he said go and talk to Judy went after
you so I went to talk to Judy and Judy
said I've just got one thing to say to
you it is the best-kept secret that
being Provost is the finest job in the
whole world
and I didn't but it's hard it's really
hard and so after eight and a half years
I was really ready to get my life back
and do some of the other things that
really interest me and also to sort of
do more of my own research and it was at
that point that the Cambridge search
committee came knocking on my door and I
I said no I didn't actually say no I
said conversation I didn't want to do it
they said oh you owe it to yourself you
owe it to Cambridge just go over for one
day so I went over for one day in the
autumn of 2002 and it turned into a
seven-year day
interesting so especially at Yale being
Provost has just huge huge
responsibilities I mean it's a very
powerful Club ostian office so Susan
when you became president at MIT did
something change so the step from the
deanship to the provost was a world
apart so when I was Dean it's a large
organization lots of moving parts but I
could still approach it the way I
approached my lab I could understand
much of what was going on at the level
of the roots and the very fan reutlitz
and feel very much in control the
Provost position is an entirely
different animal for the first time in
my life I realized that I was going to
have to rely on other people other
people's deep knowledge and I could only
take what they presented and move from
there so that was a very big change in a
little bit head spinning and I thought
how can it get more complicated than
this I don't know maybe there are people
who are wiser than I who appreciate the
complexity of these presidential roles
before they actually serve in them but I
was just you know blindsided by the
magnitude of these rules they are
enormous so at MIT we had 20,000 people
in the on-campus community the students
the faculty the you know citizens
servants who really make these places
run you know that you've got lawns to
mow you've got buildings to build you've
got investments to manage and so they
all call on your attention in time and
then you know there are the hundreds of
thousands of alumni who need your
attention
but beyond that you're tied and
intimately the concerns of your city of
your state you've got a national agenda
that has to be advanced and the
presidents of the great universities in
America played a very important role in
sculpting the National Poly's that
policies about research and education
and innovation and then you know the
panel before us about
internationalization well hey guess what
there are many nations
the world where you're also engaged and
you know you've got to show up and not
just you know be there but you've got to
understand at a significant level what's
going on this country so the size of the
role is enormous and one of the
marvelous I would say misunderstandings
of all of those people I just described
as each of them believes that you're
there for them so the undergraduates
expect you to turn up every night for
dinner the graduate students expect you
to you know be there for them the
faculty I'm like actually what are you
doing you got your feet up on the desk
well why haven't you turned up at our
whenever you come to a department
faculty meeting I thought yeah so the
just the incredible size of the
operation is enormous and I would say
the other thing I hadn't appreciated
until I was president it's not just the
kind of managerial challenges and the
the the leadership challenges in a
formal way but you also become so it's
at the heart of your institution and so
you carry these great intellectual
responsibilities but you also carry an
enormous emotional responsibility for
your institution that again I didn't
understand and I understand now that
great presidents carry all of these
responsibilities with a kind of a
lightness of spirit that's almost
inconceivable I think that's what
happens when you're really
sleep-deprived does you know so Hannah
this description that Susan's given us
of the role of president I saw this
description that susan has given us of
the role of the president of a great
great university I saw lots of nodding
heads what was the most one of the most
challenging decisions that you had to
make while you were president of Chicago
that was president of Chicago at a time
when there was a good deal of discussion
and conflict over particularly the issue
of investment or disinvestment and
companies doing business in South Africa
and that went on over more than a year
it's been over a series of years and new
groups would turn up and and when
have to discuss and think through those
issues once again and so I think it was
because of the intensity of those
discussions the length of those
discussions the complexity of the issues
involved and the situation indeed in
South Africa itself where one could not
but be in anyway in every way concerned
I think that was perhaps the most
difficult decision it wasn't a decision
I made alone but it was a decision that
I had to preside over and deal with not
only with students with faculty people
outside but also with the Board of
Trustees so I think that was in some
ways the most difficult than coming out
of the most intense period of conflict
and for you Judy hen is the largest
private employer in Philadelphia so with
all of the other obligations that
Susan's so accurately described the
obligation as economy's changed back and
forth for cities in America and
Philadelphia in particular during my
presidency anytime there was a corporate
merger the corporate headquarters moved
out of Philadelphia to wherever the next
city was that was either they acquire
and sometimes sometimes the entity being
acquired so I think the obligation of
keeping an economic engine going was
really quite significant and for that
reason when in 96 Congress passed the
balanced budget act that took out of the
payment for Graduate Medical Education
at that part which Medicare was covering
Penn had an enormous overly loaded
enterprise in not only medical medical
education but they completely horrific
aliy fertile ii vertically integrated
medical system that started with having
acquired 300 physician practices had
bought five hospitals
a number of community health facilities
and the like and in the first year we
lost ninety million dollars we were on a
trajectory for 300 million the next year
the trustees decided that they ought to
sell the medical system it was a time
when a lot of private hospital systems
were trying to make inroads into
academic medical centers they engaged an
investment banker it went incredibly far
and at the last minute I had to do a
real gut check and say this is the
institution that has the first hospital
in America Pennsylvania Hospital the
first teaching hospital in America hub
it has that tradition coming from
William Penn and Benjamin Franklin about
the practice and the application of
education that makes it at least among
the Ivy's almost unique in the way it
approaches its professional schools can
I do this and can we do this as a board
without the faculty and so it was a
moment where I had to confront my board
and ask that we start over and really go
back bring the faculty in do what we
should have done the first time the
question was the hardest decision that
you had okay then I fired the Dean
and CEO of the medical center and I had
to run it myself for five five months
one was always tempted to say David you
are at a great an important university
in a very big continent and at Cambridge
and at Oxford
you are a great important University on
a very small island those differences of
scale means that Cambridge and Oxford
are exceedingly important and big within
the context of the national setting
I believe that Yale and Harvard would
love to be so big but they just can't do
it because you can sit out at Stanford
as I'm sure and say well they think
they're the best back in the East Coast
but they're kind of stinks they don't
have any palm trees England is so small
that you don't really have that
possibility for a diversity of the best
and so that engenders a fierce pride and
also an intense resentment and when I
arrived in 2003 resentment was to the
fore and so literally on a daily basis
Cambridge and Oxford were being Hilary
above the fold on the front page of
national newspapers on a more or less
daily basis so there was a huge sort of
crisis of confidence and sort of a
temporary
if you will sort of displacement of a
shared sense of mission at both those
institutions and there was a rebuilding
to be done of that first and foremost
and then of course to build the budget
and to diversify the revenues on behind
that but the first was to get that
confidence than believe back and there's
just it's it is it is different in a way
that is geographically I was sorry to
see he was skipping over flyover country
where I did I was sorry to see you skip
over flyover country so Hana to get back
to flyover country you I think maybe the
only person who has been a fellow of the
Yale calculation and a fellow of the
Harvard corporation yes and so you know
these institutions extremely well what's
the most fun you had as a president of
the University of Chicago the most fun I
had at the president as president the
University of Chicago was making good
appointments that was the most fun you
can have when you're successful and a
really good recruitment when you're
successful in getting a really good
Provost to come those are the most
satisfying moments and they're fun too
because that becomes part of of your
Collegium so to speak and how much did
you lead us how much did I you take our
faculty
Radia probably rated us a little more
than we rated Yale but then we've always
been a more philanthropic institutions
so Susan Hannah had a lot of fun you
seem to have huge responsibilities along
with everybody else what did you do to
relax relax
so for me my family tom was a bit you
know where this oasis of of not always
calm but certainly a place to get away
from what I say wasn't 24/7 but the 36
and you know I would say I credit them
with you know my survival through the
presidency because these are just
incredibly demanding jobs that your
family takes the brunt of it if they
were complaining all the time be
impossible so you know Tom and Elizabeth
made it possible but this business of
relaxing I will share a personal story
that's probably TMI too much information
but when Elizabeth was little we were
having some issues around her getting
enough to eat I was making a valiant
effort to breastfeed and her
pediatrician said to me well gee just do
whatever you do to relax and I looked at
my said I don't relax Elizabeth there's
a thriving 22 year old so he got over
that my inability relax I think served
me well as president so Judy you now the
president of Rockefeller Foundation a
great institution different kind of
institution looking back are the
decisions that you've made in your
university administrative career that
you think you might have made
differently or that you would you know
have a different take on maybe not in in
my administrative career but in my
thinking about higher education more
broadly I think Rockefeller has given me
the opportunity to step back and really
think about a strategy almost from
scratch john d rockefeller had an
amazing vision and he won
every generation of leadership to
redefine in its own period what the
mission should be interpreted as the
mission is very broad for the betterment
of humanity and to be able to really
take risks after all film throughout the
capital is America's risk capital it's
tax-advantaged dollars in a way that
made me think could we take more risks
in the Academy as well we don't have the
same tax-advantaged dollars but we are
these amazing engines of innovation and
what I took out of the last discussion
on internationalization mostly was that
they were really thinking and talking
about process innovation and market
innovation and organizational innovation
we we in universities tend to think
about product innovation not because
we're looking for products but we're in
the lab and in the library and we're
pushing new ideas and I don't think we
take enough risks in trying to innovate
in these other domains so I think that
that is one thing that I think is really
important the second is we have and I
think appropriately so in universities a
great reverence for ideas Rockefeller
has taught me that ideas without impact
is not progress and so it's given me a
very different view about what the
obligation is in terms of what we do
with the ideas and the talent and the
new frontiers that are generated here
the third thing I would say and this is
shocking to me and I'm still thinking
through it myself I think those of us
who have been privileged enough to lead
elite universities and who really revere
the American system have been quite
reluctant to do skills-based training
for young people and
we see in the European system a
diversity of those approaches from
Germany to Scandinavia and the like
choosing kids early who may not have the
full panoply of academic options and
teaching them the skills that will give
them a successful life and I was always
vehemently opposed to that because I
think that it doesn't fulfill my view
and the American academic view of
meritocracy and opportunity but I have
to say running a foundation that invests
so much globally and really has seen
both here and around the world the
growing inequality that education even
here isn't fixing I think we need to be
open to new models and maybe our elite
perspectives are impeding some of the
models that we ought to be considering
more dramatically so that's what I've
been learning Susan also is a change of
perspective for me that has come out of
the you know my work on manufacturing in
the United States but also seeing just
the extraordinary impact of ideas into
action in in into products entities for
the marketplace and I think we
appropriately I am enormous ly concerned
about American education K through 12
education we can get to higher education
later but I think that this idea that
everyone should aspire to go to a
liberal arts college and everyone should
be educated to go to liberal arts
colleges actually closes out a huge
fraction of our population with
America's incredible flexibility in our
you know deep belief that you can
reinvent yourself at any time in your
life we actually could be serving our
young people much better by giving them
a path to success that isn't necessarily
sending them through calculus to
theoretical math but sending them
through skills development to get them
in a place where they can get their feet
under them and if they if they thrive
with that they can move into something
else California has done this very well
I think better than other states
but I think that's because there's a
real compression of higher education
with post-secondary education and
training and the term higher education
has got sort of used to encompass what
should be a whole diversity of
educational and training opportunities
one piece of which is university
education it turned out but I think I
think even even before secondary
post-secondary education we're not
serving a lot of our young people as
well as we might by teaching science and
math through theoretical physics and
theoretical math rather than where
engineering approaches to you know just
the basics so Hannah let me ask you this
because this is an ongoing discussion
and our in our country among other
places and President Obama has chosen to
stress that recently that we have to
take a new look do you think there's a
role for the leaders of what we're
calling you know the elite liberal arts
universities to play in how we think
about education in the United States how
we think about the situation of
Education yeah well I can't say that I
think the president who is a graduate of
the liberal arts education at Columbia
and of the Harvard Law School and who
taught at the University of Chicago and
lived in that neighborhood has in his
policies paid very much attention to the
tradition in which he was himself
educated that he has been much more
intent on the importance of training in
STEM much more focused on the problem of
job creation and training for jobs and
his Secretary of Education the son of a
professor at the University of Chicago
has aided and abetted that so I know I
would say I'm cautiously pessimistic an
answer to your question well let me
bring it back home if I can a little
closer to home anyway we have
brand new president the 23rd president
of Yale and from your different
perspectives if you could give Peter one
or two pieces of advice which you can
which can what advice would you give him
Judy
three things don't spill coffee on your
dissertation keep teaching figure out a
course that works with your schedule but
visiting with the undergraduates or
whatever it really isn't enough you need
to have the kind of feel whenever you
can it doesn't have to be every semester
it can't be every semester but I think
you should keep teaching obviously I
think take risks that's the lesson I
learned afterwards but I think smart
risks but take risks I think higher
education often tinkers around the edges
we have a new project or we have a new
program and this is a time the 21st
century is a moment of this intense
dynamic globalizing fast-paced changing
world
we label it technology and
internationalization but it's much more
than that
and so how you really work that and how
you think about it and then in this
great place in particular I I was
walking here and I remembered Kingman
Brewster being so roundly criticized for
speaking out and saying that he didn't
think that black revolutionaries could
get a fair trial in the United States
and it just reminded me that there was
an era in which university presidents
were really bold and spoke out not all
the time but on
really important social issues I'd love
to see you in that moment again Peter
thank you Judy Allison as I conceive of
a university it is simultaneously
community of scholars and a three
billion dollar a year organizational
business it is both of those things it
needs to be both of those things and of
course in some sense they are
irreconcilable and there is certainly a
huge tension between those sections of
this enterprise and it is in the body of
the Provost that those tensions are
worked out and brought together and
reconciled in the first instance when
the Provost fails to make it speak of
course you take it to the president but
in the first instance it is the Provost
who brings together these really
conceptions and so it is a hugely
important function
the president also plays that role but
it takes two I do believe and I when I
came to Cambridge there is there is no
history of the Provost's role in English
universities and the first thing that I
said to do was to build an undercover
Provost's role at Cambridge because you
need to have that
absolutely Susan so when I became
Provost Rick gave me the most important
advice of my life I heat it just too and
frequently and always kicked myself he
said my advice is listen listen listen I
wish I did it more frequently but what
he didn't say is something that Rick
does quite naturally which is Connect
connect connect so one of the I would
say underappreciated powers of the
president is convening power and like
Hannah you know my favorite day is the
day you're sitting around a table with a
group of really incredibly smart people
resting over some problem and someone
has an idea that no one would have had
on his or her own the path the president
can bring people together in unexpected
ways unexpected groups around you know
difficult problems or you know
brainstorming with the problems of the
future so that convening power yeah you
know I always wished I had used it more
as president it is incredibly powerful
not just to surface the ideas but to put
the ideas into action
guess what and this kind of a community
it's very hard to get an idea moving
unless it feels as though it came from
within that mystery of coming from
within also comes from this incredible
convening power Hannah advice for PETA I
am really too timid to give advice to
the president and I think everyone has
spoken very wisely and I would add just
one thing that in taking the risks that
are rightly talked about you keep in
mind the ancient proverb that two leaps
per chasm is faithful
this so we've had several questions from
the audience and they all turn on
something that we've touched on but I
think it would be helpful if we explored
a little bit more which is you've all
had great experience at Yale and then
you led other institutions what were you
know what ways are are the good parts of
Yale which ways can Yale do it
differently how do these institutions
differ Susan and my MIT reciprocal
institutions there's hardly anything
that's similar about them much to my
surprise can I just interrupt you to say
when the corporation went to visit Susan
when she was at MIT she said I want you
to notice one thing there's no place for
people to sit and eat together yes one
important difference so the thing that I
would highlight is you know just even
one of us incredible triumphs is a
residential college system so Yale has
developed this living and learning
environment to as high at art as it
exists anywhere in the world and I think
that's incredibly valuable and of course
that goes along with a very strong focus
on undergraduate education and that also
is marvelous what I saw at MIT that I
think is incredibly important for the
health of the university and I think
y'all could do more of is bringing
undergraduates into the research
enterprise we have all bought this idea
of research and education happening at
the same place by the same people that
the faculty were on the frontiers of
knowledge bring their exhilaration and
their ideas and their their
understanding back into the classroom
and that's really important but our
students are arriving on campus
incredibly sophisticated and so many of
them are
ready to engage in the front lines of
research MIT has a program that makes
that very easy and very possible in
about 85% of the students do that in
every possible discipline not just in
science or engineering but in economics
and history and in urban studies in
design and I think that Yale would
benefit tremendously by getting the
undergraduates even more involved in the
research Enterprise it's a unique
environment there are incredible people
here who could change their lives by
getting involved and also it would I
would say rebalance the university
toward a its knowledge creation
enterprise and give our our students a
sense of what it really means to be part
of this knowledge creation enterprise
HANA the difference between Yale and the
University of Chicago and how we could
prove and what can you learn from us
well I think that universities are I
mean obviously they have many
commonalities these major research
universities and obviously disciplines
across university boundaries and
therefore so much of what happens in
terms of the research enterprise really
is not distinctive for a given
institution even though a certain school
of thought might arise of a certain
institution but then it hops over those
those borders I think the differences
between institutions have a lot to do
with their history and being a historian
I better think so or I wouldn't have a
profession but it does have a lot to do
with their history for example the
University of Chicago was founded as a
university it was founded and it began
its work in 1892 and there was a
founding president who came from Yale
which tried to keep him by having him
have two chairs instead of just one but
only one and a half salaries right
and it was a difficult thing to get him
to come from Yale to the University of
Chicago this new enterprise which mr.
Rockefeller was going to fund the
beginnings of but he did and what was it
that he wanted to do he wanted to do
something that he didn't see anywhere
else where in the country he wanted to
found a university he was not building a
university on an already existing
College and of course the history of
Yale like the history of Harvard
whatever their great differences too is
that there were colleges and then there
came to be added graduate schools and so
on and this is still reflected in their
modes of governance it is reflected in
the fact that neither Yale no Harvard
for example has an all university
faculty governing body but that each
faculty is the governing body that the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences in each
case is sort of seen as the faculty
governance of the university despite the
fact that there were all these other
faculties as well so the University of
Chicago was founded by a
research-oriented founding president who
on the whole would have preferred not to
have the first two years of an
undergraduate college if he could have
helped it but he couldn't help it and
who therefore founded a university that
sort of sprang into university life as
at the outset and that created a
tremendous difference in the tradition
of the University and the history of the
university the role of accident is also
important in the role of leadership
another very important leader of the
University of Chicago who also came from
Yale where he failed find satisfaction
the age of 29 although he was Dean of
the law school of course robert maynard
hutchins and interestingly he focused on
undergraduate education as harper had
focused on graduate education
scholarship research and so forth and
made that really the key to the
evaluation of faculty and the quality of
the place Hutchins who took on the same
University that had become a major
university was interested in
undergraduate education was very
suspicious of
of professional education very
suspicious indeed of many of the
disciplines that we take for granted in
education including history didn't think
history amounted to much there was over
metaphysics in history and he didn't
like that
so our university became an interesting
compound of an unusual undergraduate
college which however much it ultimately
departed from the Hutchins model still
bears its imprint in many ways and a
research university oriented toward
toward graduate training and one in
which the professional schools are a
part of the university at Yale you're an
alumnus or alumna of the University if
you graduated from Yale College the
University of Chicago you're an alumnus
of the University that's the difference
billions of stings Allisyn came with the
way that you came to do with a bright 18
year old and what the US thinks you do
with the bright 18 they're completely
different no different I think that some
but I think maybe this translates into
advice either I don't I think what we
should try to do more of is to be really
open against what it is others are doing
not to do what they do but to sort of to
see I'm actually reminded that in the
context Cambridge and MIT had very well
organized exchange program for
undergraduates and of course the
students for them it was a wonderful
kind of study abroad experience what was
really interesting about that was the
academics who were very involved and
they saw in each other students
qualities and capacities that they
didn't see in their own students and it
didn't translate back into a revolution
in the way that undergraduate education
was going on but it did translate back
into people doing things differently in
Cambridge people trying new things at
MIT and in fact Cambridge began the
undergraduate research Opportunity
Program precisely because the Cambridge
academics or how about was galvanising
MIT students we there's a lot of study
abroad and study here and study there
but I don't think we actually take very
seriously the opportunity as
institutions to learn from that
diversity open those experiences sure
Judy I actually will start with there
and it would at that point and say that
there are so many ways that we exhort
our students to do X Y or Z to engage in
research or to become civically engaged
or but the best way is to really
demonstrate that as institutions
ourselves and one of the things that I
think Penn had the opportunity to do
because it was so inextricably bound
with Philadelphia was really demonstrate
what a civically engaged institution
looked like in a way that was so
compelling to our students and our
faculty I remember as we were trying to
transform the West Philadelphia
neighborhood and many years later
walking and bumping into the chairman of
the math department who was a
theoretical mathematician in the summer
and
said oh I'm writing an NSF fellowship I
could kill you and I said why he said I
am the theoretical mathematician if
anybody ever told me that I'd be
spending my summer vacation writing an
NSF grant for K through 12 math
curriculum for West Philadelphia I would
have said they were crazy but it became
really part of what we felt proud of and
what our students learn from us Susan
mentioned in talking about the quartet
which is probably a little Yale secret
but what's so unusual and what I missed
at Penton actually was the
extraordinarily close relationship that
the president the provost the dean of
graduate school and the Dean of the
college had a weekly lunches constant
conversation and intensity around the
liberal arts curriculum and what that
means at Yale and and how to really
continue not at the expense of the
professional schools but for the benefit
of the professional schools and for the
benefit of the Academy
it is so central in a way that I marvel
at and respect deeply so time ticks and
so I'm gonna ask each of you do you have
any advice for young women and young men
who may aspire to careers - assuming
positions as complex and demanding as
you have done Allison
advice I would say great
when I was between programs by the pork
that Milhouse Avenue and my comics and
anthropology would would look at me in
their lip would curl and they would say
and how is it being an administration
right would say and do you know what
they're doing now and I would say I am
babe what's your problem
there is administration represents a
threat to the chaos and anarchy of
academia so getting you know getting
people to imagine that it is as you said
to me it is a wonderful interesting job
and I never did any administration so
whenever I meet young people who express
any glimmering of interest in doing this
evil job I just always say it's Hana
advice for the next generation well I'm
often asked by younger people about how
they should prepare and I'm always
slightly appalled by it because I
believe that the administration of these
great universities ought to be conducted
by intellectuals ought to be conducted
by people who are themselves scholars
and of a significant sort ought to be
conducted by people who who care about
the classroom who care about the
relationship of the different
disciplines so I want some of the very
best people in academia to back into it
the way at this table probably has not
not arriving at where we arrive because
we had planned it or because we had
trained for it but because it just sort
of happened that one thing led to
another and
that led to something else and gosh it
was kind of surprising in a way I think
that it is great if younger people think
of university administration is
something that is important because it
is important because it is important to
maintain the institution's it is
important to maintain the the spiritual
values that they represent and the
intellectual potential that they
represent I also think that if the
universities are not run by people for
whom the intellectual purpose is the
driving purpose our universities are
going to fall further and further into a
deteriorating state which I mean that
they will become more and more
multitaskers without a clarity of
purpose that our academic mission ought
to want to express and they ought to be
the advocates for that and be courageous
advocates for that so I think that would
be well what I always say to young
people is you know be very good at what
you're doing and involve yourself as
good citizens of the university because
good citizens of the university are too
rare and our universities depend on them
depend on the faculty who are good
citizens and depend on some of those
faculty to become the administrators and
I think that the Yale's tradition of
leadership is significant in that
respect and wanted to be lauded and
continued Thank You Hannah Judy penny
when she started I think appropriately
acknowledged all of the other Provost's
who have become presidents in the
audience but this panel is a panel of
women Provost's who became women
presidents so I will not give advice to
the men
but I would like to say something to the
young women obviously we've all talked
about not planning too much things
happen you can't plan for these careers
you can only plan to be excellent at
what you are doing and then things
happen but I keep at my desk still a
cartoon that was in The New Yorker
several years ago it has all men sitting
around the table and one woman and a man
is at the head of the table and the
woman has obviously just spoken and he
says that it was a wonderful comment
Miss Smith now maybe one of the men
would like to make it so even today my
advice to young women women is this will
happen to you at some point in your
career don't be defeated by it I hope
for examples of the fact that we weren't
defeated by it and Susan the last word I
really have very little to add to what
these three great Provost presidents
have said and I concur with them
entirely I think the one of the
paradoxes of the university is that we
reward we promote our faculty for
essentially non collegial skills you get
tenure because you have gone someplace
where no one has gone before on your own
right of course you work as people do it
and then we turn around and say and now
could you please depart be a department
chair and get everyone to work together
you know that so it's not for everyone
but among the faculty at a great
university are people who actually can
play both axes they can play
independently and they can play together
and finding those people and giving them
the encouragement you know to step up I
just want to you know close with a
comment about the importance of academic
leadership in a university it's well-run
the faculty have this incredible luxury
of
knowing how the place gets running not
caring you just do your thing we create
conditions so that the faculty can do
things that they never dreamed they
could do before which is marvelous and
so and this curling of the lip of course
is you know certainly how I viewed the
administration before it became they and
when I when Rick and Alison had
persuaded me to take on the Dean of the
Graduate teach with the Graduate School
I had a couple of people I just had to
tell before it was announced and one was
Jim Watson who had been my boss the
director of the Cold Spring Harbor
Laboratory my mentor and it was with a
very great deal of anxiety that I called
him up to confess that I had made the
decision to go to the dark side and I
told him the news and without a pause he
said that's fantastic most people don't
understand that it matters who runs a
university great confirmation and I have
to tell you that being part of the
leadership of Yale University was just
an extraordinary experience for me I
studied at the Levins school of college
and university leadership the L school
and you know you can see it's a very
effective school we learned the lessons
and then promulgate the lessons from
Yale around the world so it's a
privilege to have done that it's a
privilege to be here today and what
great fun to be with my colleagues
absolutely
so would you join me in thanking
you